it did you're notoriously like a sober
guy right not like a guy who is an
alcoholic who just never got loaded
no I just I'm just fortunate I don't
have the um
the thing in your veins where like you
have to have like you know like I'm good
with just two glasses of wine you know
what I mean I'm good you know I'm good
with uh you know you know joint you know
just a little bit yeah just a little bit
I I just never um had that that like you
said that ISM yeah like my dad had it my
dad was sober 40 50 years Mike binder
has it a lot of people have it where
they can't
you know so I was just lucky I didn't
have that so but I'm not definitely not
sober okay good yeah I'm not so I'm not
sober you know it's called Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
Amazon and type in Stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and Order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of Amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on Amazon and
buy Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude